the media the corporate press the  mainstream media just lies to us about  everything when it's their guys burning  down the cities and destroying best buys  and targets and pep boys and whatever  else those are the good guys and we  should be tolerant of it mostly a  protest uh it is not uh it is not  generally speaking unruly are you blind  are you blind you're seeing behind me is  one of multiple locations that have been  burning in kenosha wisconsin so peaceful  show me where it says that protests are  supposed to be polite and peaceful but  when it's peaceful people you know  protesting for freedom they're bad guys  they're right-wing maniacs alt-right etc  etc insurrection a threat to democracy a  nationwide insurrection driven by  madness there have not been any violent  outbursts however horns have been  honking  it's truly incredible watching these  people flip the story